What should be my next step in this journey? I've been on my protocol and fed men since June 1,
more blood testing or another test, feeling great but kind of confused. Well, we could talk
number one, so you could set up a time when we could chat. That could be a possibility.
Number two, remember if you're unfendmen and it has affected your liver enzymes,
you should consider getting another comprehensive metabolic profile to make sure
it isn't making things worse again. That should be in the mix. Number three, doing another
cheek swab test would be a possibility too. So I do have a video, this is a good question.
Like when should I do another cheek swab or when should I do another lap? Number one, if I didn't
tell you, if you don't remember me telling you you need to do with other lab this much time,
then you could ask on this forum here. So this is a good place to ask a question like this.
You could make an appointment and ask about next steps.
Well, too often we see people just kind of fully off, they feel great and they just disappear.
And we don't know whatever happened to the grid, we're like, oh my gosh, whatever happened
in this person, we haven't heard from them for months, they call them and oh, I'm doing great.
Well, that's good. We don't want you to feel like you have to connect to us.
But we also don't want you to fall through the cracks and not get labs when we should get labs too
because you know, something could be going on and we want to make sure we're staying on top of that,
especially if you're on bed as long as I remember back then you want to make sure
that it's not affected your liver negatively because you may not feel what a quote the effects
liver toxicity until something drastic happens. So getting a blood test as long as you're
open-possed AST, ALT or within normal limits and you're doing great, then there isn't really any,
I would tell you, there are really any problems that I need to do a cheek swab test that will keep
going and it's protocol, but we just want to make sure there's not any toxicity going on in your
liver that you're not apprehending it any.